Marina marshes in Essex are a paradise
for birds and on their tail are the
Twitches they are a sizable Army and now
the rspb and other Wildlife Charities
are joining forces threatening to
mobilize millions of members to fight
off what they fear a government plans to
sacrifice the environment in the dash
for economic growth you can sense their
urgency if the insects are going then
the animals and birds that rely on them
will disappear and then eventually it
will affect us and it will affect us
really badly that's going to have a
knock-on effect for for decades and
generations to come and it's something
we absolutely have to fight against what
sort of message are we giving children
if we then start destroying our
environmental saying it's not important
the government has given no commitment
to keeping hundreds of regulations that
protect plants and animals and set
standards for air and water quality and
incentives for Farmers to enhance nature
could also be plowed up
Wildlife Charities say it's an assault
on nature already 41 of UK plant and
animal species are in Decline 15 are
threatened with Extinction they say now
is the time to strengthen Environmental
Protection not weaken it the former
environment Minister said ripping up
protections would be a mistake not least
in agriculture the way you get growth is
by having healthy soils a healthy
environment and actually embracing some
of those regenerative agricultural
techniques that our new policy was all
about encouraging and if you you know
abandon that then I think you're into in
a bad position both for the resilience
of farming financially but also for
nature a test of the government's
commitment to the environment will be
its new investment zones in the Kent
Countryside campaigners fear plans for
eight and a half thousand homes on Green
Fields could be rushed through as part
of unbridled development we've got some
sensible rules that do require
developers to make reasonable efforts to
make what they build beautiful
deliverable sustainable in the right
place with the right amounts of Green
Space transport infrastructure but
within an investment zone I'm not seeing
anything that would stop people building
whatever they wanted wherever they
wanted because the rules would simply
presuppose permission had be given the
government said investment zones would
deliver jobs and housing for local
communities and it's committed to
reversing the decline of nature by 2030
but Wildlife groups worn growth must not
come at any cost Thomas More Sky News